بحلول فصل الخريف سندمر كامل ترسانتنا من
الاسلحه الكيميائيه هذا ما اعلن عنه مؤخرا
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لكن لماذا تدمر
واشنطن هذا النوع من الاسلحه الان الاجابه
على هذا السؤال يجب ان نعود بالزمن الى
عام
1997 حيث كان الاعلان عن اتفاقيه حظر
الاسلحه الكيميائيه وتصنيعها وتدمير ما
يوجد منها 165 دوله وقعت على هذه
الاتفاقيه من بينها روسيا وامريكا روسيا
كانت انتهت من تنفيذ بنود الاتفاقيه في
السابع والعشرين من سبتمبر عام 2017 غير
ان امريكا لم تنفذها ليومنا هذا ودمرت
جزءا فقط من ترسانتها الكيميائيه هذا
الامر دفع روسيا الى اتهام امريكا
بالمماطله في تنفيذ بنود الاتفاقيه قائله
انها لا تزال تحتفظ بثلاثه بالمئه من
مخزونها من الاسلحه الكيميائيه التي تشكل
خطرا كبيرا على العالم